the definition of high-concept sometimes
I struggle with it myself and then I
hear it and I go okay and I forget
though generally it's considered an idea
that you can that that's is very easily
understandable in a kind of a sentence a
couple of sentences you know if you're
pitching something pitch a high pitch a
high concept three secretaries conspired
to murder their boss 9:00 to 5:00 you
know an actor dresses as a woman to get
to get a job on a soap opera because he
can't get any other work and learns to
be learns to appreciate women more as a
result of it tutsi I mean that kind of
thing you know something that has a high
now again those movies are quite a
little less a little less popular now
those high concept comedies or those
high concept ideas but you still need a
concept that is strong and simple to to
understand and for people to get you
know what how will they market it you
know what will be on the poster what
will be in the trailer versus people to
get it you know and it doesn't have to
be anything that that while did that
imaginative but it says to be relatively
simple to state otherwise sometimes
ideas get so complicated that they get
very convoluted and that shows up in the
in the writing and sometimes the film
itself so it's about keeping it simple
but interesting and and and I don't know
if lack of a better word clever and and
unique so can someone sort of bounce
that idea off someone that like hey you
know this is sort of the logline for my
script or whatever and and if the person
just doesn't get it then they know I
need to refine it right right I mean I I
mean I definitely gone in to pitch ideas
you know this for a film or TV pilot or
something and you know I I think I get
it and I think it's a good idea and then
some of us and well I like the idea it's
a little complicated though because
because of a B and C and and not to me
it's like oh well yeah I get it you know
I know I know what the idea I can
totally see how this idea can work but
if I were to write that idea myself and
sometimes I'll go back and try to
outline it a little bit just to see if
to test it and I'll realize yeah I just
cut it is a little complicated it sounds
high-concept it sounds simple and fun
and you can see what the movie is you
can see the whole movies like a carpet
that rolls out in front of you you can
just see the whole thing what it is but
sometimes it's not
sometimes it is more complicated than
you think so there has to be kind of a a
you know sometimes people say god I wish
I thought of that idea you know
sometimes just this simple beautiful in
the simplicity you know and yet again
three secretaries conspired to murder
their boss you know a comedy you just
something that's just simple and people
relate to and people get I mean you know
I've written a lot of high concept
comedies and it's just kind of a hard to
explain it's like this thing you know it
when you hear it right right but but
like you know my movie Manhattan
Transfer you know I gave you the log
lines the high-concept radio shrink
takes us to take on the neuroses of all
of his callers on this the most
important week of his life yeah you see
what the movies about it's a high
concept but they're they're hard to come
by nowadays they they don't make quite
as many of those as films and I'll make
quite as many of those high concept
movies often were comedies sometimes
they were you know die hard was high
concept you know what Lethal Weapon was
a high concept you know just just just
you know you could express the idea of
the movie in you know a sentence or two
and you totally got it you know that's
kind of what it is you may see more than
a television now you know I don't know
you know if I was if I anytime I would
I'm going to pitch something you know
I'm trying to go and you try to go in
and pitch something that's that's
relatively clear and simple to
understand in terms of what the world is
going to be what where the entertainment
value is going to come from where the
conflict can be in a lot of it is just
inherent in those couple of sentences
and and sometimes it makes a good film
or TV series sometimes it doesn't you
know it's not everything but if you've
got a good character attached to it you
know chances are you have a good shot of
at least having a good piece of material
from it so if it's too wordy it needs to
be reduced yeah and you know like
anything that if you when you start
explaining anything to somebody you know
and wait and people who are not sort of
natural pictures of stories or don't do
it for a living or whatever you know
somebody's like somebody will come to me
and say I just had the most amazing
experience you've got to write a movie
about this and what is it and they'll
say well okay I was standing on a street
corner and before you know it they're
talking for 20 minutes about this story
you're lost you got lost that minute for
and this there's no story to it or you
think this something funny but
just too complicated what's the movie
what's the story you know why am I gonna
laugh what I do with that you know
there's a lot of that so yeah you have
to keep it you have to keep it simple
you know and unique
you